VIVIAN ZHONG: Hi, my
name is Vivian Zhong.
I'm a junior working in the Alm
Lab doing microbiome research.
And my current project revolves
around this treatment called
fecal microbiota transplant.
This treatment involves taking
the stool from a healthy donor
and transplanting into
the gut of a sick patient.
And this is a really
effective cure
for a disease called
recurrent c-diff infection.
However, it's not
really that effective
in many other diseases
that are similarly related
to the microbiome.
And we want to look into what
affects the efficacy of FMT.
What factors play
into whether or not
the bacteria in the donor's
stool colonize the patient gut?
And so the two factors that
we looked into in my project--
one is whether or not the
stool, prior to transplantation,
was exposed oxygen or not.
The idea behind this
is that your gut is
a very oxygen-deficient
environment,
but the usual processing
method currently used
in clinical trials
and in medical centers
involves exposing the stool
to a large amount of oxygen.
And so perhaps that's
enough to alter
the microbiome composition
of the donor stool sample
enough that it impacts how
well the bacteria colonize
the patient.
And the second factor is
to look at whether or not,
perhaps, the sheer
difference in the donor.
Since everybody has a
very different microbiota
composition, perhaps just
inter-donor variations
have a large effect on how
the donor's stool interacts
with the patient.
So did a clinical trial with
three donors and 11 patients.
We took stool samples from the
donor and from the patient,
both before and at
four time points
after the treatment was given.
And long story short, we
looked at the composition
of the stool samples.
And so far, it doesn't seem like
there's a really large signal
to indicate any difference
between patients that were
treated with oxygen-exposed or
not-exposed-to-oxygen stool.
And what might be either
covering any signal
from that effect, or which
might be more important than
whether or not the stool
was exposed to oxygen,
is the inter-donor variations.
Preliminary results
indicate that the stool
from one of the donors
was perhaps worse
than the other two
donors for the bacteria
to colonize in the patient gut.
And in the future I'm
going to do some more
analysis of the
data, looking more
at specific bacteria,
whether those perhaps
do differ between oxygen
and non-oxygen-exposed,
and also, looking more at are
the donor-specific effects
because of the differences
in the composition?
Are they perhaps artifacts
of how they were processed?
To try to get to the bottom
of the mechanism behind FMT.